bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans sa vous regarde ce
soir une figure inquiète de la droite
conservatrice en France bonsoir Eugénie
Bastier et merci d'être notre grand
témoin cette inquiétude et bien elle
parcourt votre dernier livre la
dictature des ressentis chez plomb c'est
une déconstruction minutieuse de ce
qu'on appelle la pensée W que vous voyez
prendre une ampleur dangereuse dans
notre pays on va en parler et le remède
c'est la littérature des grands
écrivains d'hier pour aujourd'hui vous
nous direz lesquels tout à l'heure notre
grand débat ce soir faut-il supprimer la
Cour de Justice de la République c'est
une situation assez surréaliste un
ministre de la Justice en exercice qui
se rend à son propre procès une première
sous la 5e République qui se déroule
depuis lundi devant une cour composée de
députés des hommes et des femmes
politiques qui jugent l'un des leur une
exception bien française faut qui mettre
fin nous en débattons dans un instant
sur ce plateau enfin nous affranchi ce
soir le parti prix politique de yelgose
le billet philo de Pierre-Henri tavoyot
et puis Bourbon Express bien sûr signé
Elsa Mondin Gava voilà pour le programme
on y va Eugénie Bastier PL ça vous
regarde c'est
[Musique]
maintenant Éric Dupont Moretti soupçonné
de vouloir régler ses comptes avec
plusieurs magistrats croisés durant sa
longue carrière d'avocat depuis
l'ouverture du procès ce lundi le
malaise et palpable conflit d'intérêts
pour les uns gouvernement des juges pour
les autres la neutralité même de la cour
devant laquelle il est entendu et
contesté alors qu'est-ce qui ne va pas
et qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait changer
bonsoir Christopher weisberg bonsoir
merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance des Français établis en
Amérique du Nord vous débattez ce soir
avec Benjamin Lucas bonsoir bienvenue
député Europe Écologie les vers des
ivelines bonsoir Denis alas ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau vous êtes
magistrat essayiste et vous présidez
l'Association française pour l'histoire
de la justice votre dernier ouvrage qui
n'a rien à voir avec ce débat mais je le
signale quand même le dénis du viol chez
Michalon enfin bonsoir Paul Cassia
bonsoir ravi de vous retrouver également
vous êtes professeur de droit public à
l'université Panthéon Sorbonne et vous
êtes vice-président de l'association
antiorps vous avez été entendu mardi
dernier
comme témoin devant cette Cour de
Justice de la République vous nous direz
un peu comment ça s'est passé et ce que
vous reprochez au garde d' saau Eugénie
Bastier vous intervenez quand vous le
souhaitez ça va de soi on va commencer
par planter le décor et il est baroque
ce soir un ministre de la justice devant
la justice le chrono de blackco tout de
suite et je me retourne pour vous
accueillir mon cher Stéphane blackovski
bonsoir bonsoir Miriam bonsoir à toutes
et tous alors depuis début de la semaine
le le ministre de la Justice comparaît
devant la cour de justice de la
République qui est la seule juridiction
habilité à juger des ministres qui ont
commis qui ont reproche en tout cas des
délits ou des crimes commis dans
l'exercice de leur fonction donc je vous
fais un petit rappel vous avez peut-être
sui ça dans la presse la CJR c'est comme
ça qu'on l'appelle hein est composé de
15 juges 12 parlementaires donc moitié
Sénat moitié Assemblée nationale et
seulement trois magistrats
professionnels alors je vous connais
vous posez une question vous dit mais
est-ce que le ministre exercit son
métier alors qu'il est convoqué à un
procès et bien voici la réponse du
ministre d'abord moi je me lève très
très tôt voyez par exemple je me lève à
4h du matin 5h tous les jours quand 5h
quand je fais une grass matinée donc
pour signer les parffurs ça ira très
bien j'espère que vous êtes rassuré tout
cas oui impressionné matinaliier le Eric
Dupont moriti est donc accusé de prise
illégale d'intérêt c'estd qu'on lui
reproche d'avoir ordonné une enquête
administrative contre des magistrats du
du pôle national financier avec qui il
était en conflit euh lorsqu'il était
avocat il leur reprochait de l'avoir
espionné sur ses communications
téléphoniques donc en clair ce qu'on
reproche à l'ancien avocat c'est d'avoir
profité d'être nommé ministre pour
régler ses comptes avec des magistrats
qu'il n'aimaent pas cela dit quand on se
replangeche dans l'affaire on se rend
compte qu'on pourrait poser la question
exactement inverse est-ce que ce ne
serait pas les magistrats qui auraient
tenté de prendre une revanche sur ce
ministre parce que je vous rappelle que
une semaine seulement avoir d'avoir été
nommé garde des saut et bien ériic
Dupont Moretti fidèle à sa tradition a
fait des déclaration Tony Truand dans Le
Parisien où il expliquait que en France
nous avions basculé dans la République
des juges et en soulignant que dans
notre pays les juges ne sont jamais ou
quasiment jamais sanctionnés lorsqu'ils
font des erreurs et il citait en exemple
l'affaire d'outra donc l'un des pires
fiasc judiciaires de notre histoire dans
laquelle le juge responsable s'était vu
infliger une réprimande ce qui est la
plus faible sanction possible donc
résultat une semaine après cette
interview quand éric duupont moriti est
nommé garde des saau bien les syndicats
de magistrats voie rougge ils estiment
que c'est une déclaration de guerre
contre leur profession donc ils vont
mener une guerre contre le ministre qui
va aller loin puisque quelques mois plus
tard ils vont aller jusqu'à écrire à la
Commission européenne pour demander la
démission du ministre mais il y a pas
que les syndicats qui sont en guerre
contre le ministre regardez à l'époque
les deux au magistrat qui était François
boonins et chantalarins du pays ont
publié une tribune dans Le Monde dans
laquelle ben voilà il reprochait au
ministres d'avoir ouvert une enquête
contre des magistrats alors évidemment
on peut s'interroger sur leur motivation
défendre la justice he j'imagine mais
est-ce qu'il n'avaient pas aussi de leur
côté envie de se payer la tête d'un
ministre qui ne leur revenait pas
prenons cas François Molins par exemple
vous savez que on a cru qu'il serait
nomit ministre de l'Intérieur et puis ça
lui a échappé on a cru qu'il serait
nommait ministre de la justice et puis
c'est Éric du petti qui a été nommé à sa
place serait-il jaloux je ne sais pas
c'est une question que je pose en tout
cas si les magistrats croyaient obtenir
la tête du ministre en le mettant en
examen et ben ils se sont trompés parce
que le Président de la République a bien
précisé qu'il n'avait pas du tout
l'intention de leur céder on l'écoute
quand des des syndicats de magistrats
décident de lancer une procédure contte
un garde d'essau il le fond dans
instance il siège même je je considère
que je ne rendrai pas service à la
démocratie en cédant à ce que je ne
considère pas comme un fonctionnement
satisfaisant alors au final qu'est-ce
qui va rester de cette affaire bien
j'imagine que si le ministre est relaxé
on va dire ah vous voyez la justice et
l'xiste avec les ministres mais si en
revanche il est condamné on va dire ah
vous voyez décidément ce sont les juges
qui décident de tout dans ce pays bon je
crois que le débat est ouvert hein il
est ouvert c'est un regard de Stéphane
blackakowski ce billet ce soir
Christopher weisberg je commence avec
vous parce que c'est intéressant vous
connaissez bien les États-Unis euh vous
êtes vous êtes le député des des
Français qui habitent là-bas c'est une
c'est une grande démocratie est-ce que
vous pensez une seule seconde que cette
situation un ministre de la Justice en
exercice qui sera à son propre procès
euh puisse être possible dans un pays
comme celui-là aux États-Unis vous
voulez dire bah écoutez c'est un bon
exemple on est on parle de la
responsabilité d'un dirigeant quand il
est au pouvoir euh aux États-Unis il y a
une procédure qui est une procédure
politique ça s'appelle la procédure
d'impeachment la procédure d'impeachment
elle est régul elle est pour les
présidents non non elle est pas que pour
les présidents n'importe quel au
fonctionnaire n'importe quelle
institution n'importe quelle ministre
peut aussi faire preuve d'une procédure
d'impeachment c'est la manière de
disqualifier dans un dans un procès qui
est un procès politique et donc
évidemment c'est très difficile de juger
des gens qui sont en responsabilité moi
je trouve et le débat est ouvert que
évidemment cette cour de justice c'est
une réponse à la française je crois
qu'il n'y a pas de réponse parfaite ça
veut dire quoi ça une réponse à la
française bah c'est la réponse qu'on met
quand même trois magistrats on met des
députés des députés d'opposition il y a
h députés d'opposition et quatre de la
majorité il y a Daniel auonau dont on
peut absolument pas dire qu'elle est
très favorable au gouvernement et donc
il y a quand on regarde la composition
objectivement plus de gens qui ne sont
pas acquis à la cause du ministre que le
contraire donc moi je trouve que c'est
une manière de réger il y a toujours eu
des débats sur réformer cette cours C
députés de la
majorité un débat ça n'est jamais un
débat qui est facile à trancher puisque
comme toujours quand on est en
responsabilité on prend des décisions et
ces décisions elles peuvent être
toujours attaqué et condamné il s pas
mis en retrait ça c'est une question
importante certains réclament au moins
si ce n sa démission qu'il se mettent en
retrait les quelques jours de son procès
là il dit je suis matinale je signe mes
parafurs à 4h du matin est-ce que est-ce
que c'est ça donne une bonne image là je
parle deun peu de l'éthique c'est pas
uniquement la question légale se pose
est-ce que on a l'impression d'un
abandon de poste un peu quand même
comment comment comment tenir la place
vendô dans ces conditions on déjà le
procès il est court il est court c'est
pas un procès qui va durer des mois ou
des années donc ça veut dire que c'est
une période très très spécifique
évidemment le faire le sortir de ces
fonctions bah déjà ça mettrait aussi un
peu à risque la fonction parce que c'est
quand même le garde des saau qui gère
les dossiers au quotidien quelqu'un pour
l'occuper non mais on trouve toujours
quelqu'un je suppose qu'il y aurait
quand même des candidats à être mis de
la justice chez les macronis vous êtes
pas à ce niveau de de désespoir alors ça
ça dépend est-ce que vous parlez de
démettre quelqu'un alors là ce serait
complètement contraire à sa présomption
d'innocence et sera admettre dès le
départ qu'il ne peut pas être en
fonction puisqu'il est coupable donc moi
je trouve pas du tout que sur une
période aussi courte ça comporte un
risque pour la justice qu'il reste en
fonction dernière petite question je
fais tourner la parole parce que vous
avez parlé de la présomption d'innocence
il y a un changement de jurisprudence
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 après
laaffaire Fillon Emmanuel Macron promet
la République exemplaire et et dicte la
règle baladure euh simple mise en examen
égale démission sortie du gouvernement
et puis là c'est l'inverse qui se passe
euh est-ce que il n'y a pas un problème
pour simplement la compréhension des des
Français pourquoi il changeent d'avis
depuis le début depuis le premier jour
où ce ministre a été nommé il y a un
risque qu'il soit attaqué en justice par
la corporation qu'il est censé euh euh
sur laquelle il est censé travailler
donc depuis le début on sait représenter
et donc depuis le début on le sait il y
avait ris très fort et ce qu'avait dit
le président de la République je trouve
que c'est juste c'est qu'au fond c'était
cédé à un chantage si on n'acceptait pas
que cet homme qui a quand même sa
carrière derrière lui pour prouver qu'il
est un une personne qui est légitime
pour avoir ses fonctions si on avait
décidé dès le début qu'il serait attaqué
par la magistrature et donc il fallait
pas qu'il pr la fonction c'était cédé au
chantage et ça n'a pas été fait pour le
reste je tiens m
direti qu'est-ce que vous inspire la
situation c'est vrai que c'est drôle
parce que en même temps il y a un autre
procè c'est celui de franis qui lui-même
était garde des saut et qui est euh qui
est sorti et qui a décidé de partir pour
se défendre et pour des raisons pour des
raisons éthique il était mis en examen
et son procès pour des des affaires
d'assistants parlementaires avec des des
soupçons de détournement son est est en
ce moment même pour vous il y a deux
poids de mesurees être ministre de la
République c'est pas un droit ça vous
parlez de la question de la présomption
d'innocence elle n'est pas en cause moi
j'appelle à ce que Éric Dupont Moretti
quitte ses fonctions je ne préjuge
absolument pas ni du fond du dossier
dont n'ai pas sur lequel je n'ai pas à
m'exprimer ni de ce qui sera décidé
simplement quand on a l'honneur d'être
ministre de la République imaginez garde
des saut vous succédez à Robert Badinter
quand même enfin c'est c'est pas rien
dans dans dans ce qui est notre
République vous avez le devoir d'être
totalement à votre tâche et qu'il n'y
ait pas le risque d'une suspicion sur
votre probité c'est ce qui avait
d'ailleurs conduit Emmanuel Macron à
juste titre dans la campagne de 2017 à
dire un ministre mis en examen ne pourra
pas rester ministre c'est une bonne
règle ça s'est appliqué par le passé à
d'autres je le redis être ministre de la
République ce n'est pas un droit et on a
quand même un personnel politique un
personnel judiciaire dans ce pays qui
est suffisamment fourni pour qu'on soit
capable même si plus grand monde veut
rentrer dans les gouvernements
d'Emmanuel Macron pour qu'on soit
capable de trouver un nouveau garde des
saau la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
a de fait un ministre de la Justice qui
est jugé dans le cadre d'une d'une cour
de justice on y reviendra qui est une
forme d'anomalie institutionnelle et en
plus il y a un procureur dont il est le
supérieur et qu'il a nommé lui-même en
tout ça quand même au-delà
hiérarchiquement chef des magistrats des
procureurs qui qui l'accus dans ce proc
du fond tout ça donne on est dans un
moment où la démocratie ne va pas bien
dans un moment où beaucoup de nos
compatriotes s'interrogent sur la vie la
vitalité de notre démocratie où le pays
est en tension on a en ce moment par
ailleurs une tension j'ai pas besoin de
la décrire dans le pays une menace
terroriste un contexte international qui
fait que les gens sont inquiets sont
angoissés on a besoin que le
gouvernement puisse faire son travail
voilà moi je dis comme opposant je veux
m'opposer à la politique qu'il mène mais
je veux qu'il puisse conduire sa
politique dans de bonnes conditions là
le ministre de la Justice n'est
manifestement pas en situation de faire
juste le président de la République doit
choisir entre préserver son cl clan et
l'intérêt général et la République je
pense que malheureusement il préserve le
clan on l'a vu sur benala on l'a vu sur
l'affire colur on l'a vu sur un certain
nombre de sujets on préserve le clan
c'est dommage c'est regrettable avec
Monsieur baayrou il avait eu la main
beaucoup plus lourde et il avait eu
raison de le faire al François Baayou
dit que c'est lui qui a voulu
démissionné de son propre
chef il faut bien comprendre parce que
les gens qui nous regardent l'affaire
elle est très complexe mais il faut bien
comprendre qu'il est jugé pour conflit
d'intérêts dupontetti avec des juges et
des procureurs qu'il a lui-même nommé
ouii tout à fait configuration et ça
c'est totalement inédit sur la 5e ah ou
totalement totalement non seulement il
il est le le SU hiérarchique du
procureur qui tient la barre du
ministère public à l'audience mais
également de des juges même dont il
maîtrise les décrets de nomination donc
il y a une sorte de de de de regard un
peu comme ça paradoxal sur une
juridiction où il est à la fois euh en
position de domination statutaire et en
même temps de prévenu donc donc déjà on
est on est là la deuxième chose c'est
qu'il faut souligner dans cette
juridiction extrêmement curieuse c'est
l'absence de partie civil parce que
effffectivement ceux qui sont à
l'origine de la plainte les syndicats de
magistrats et l'assoation handicor ne
sont pas présents à l'audience et Paul
casscia n'a été là que comme témoin
c'est ça parce que les partis civils
dans un procès classique ce sont eux qui
portent l'accusation souvent même plus
fortement que le ministère public VO qui
porte questions les plus inconfortables
pour le pour le ministre et la troisième
chose qu'il faudrait souligner c'est
comment ça démarre cette affaire
là le ministre se plaint d'une d'une
accusation scandaleuse une ignominie ou
une infamie et cetera donc on a le
sentiment si vous voulez que on on a
face à face deux deux adversaires dont
chacun veut emporter la victoire et je
trouve que c'est vraiment dommage d'en
arriver là parce que on voudrait on a
besoin de savoir la vérité on pas on n
pas besoin de savoir qui va gagner par
Rapp dans une tribune au Monde vous
doutez de l'apport du procès d'Erc du
pontoretti au débat sur la
responsabilité des gouvernants oui
absolument absolument parce que la
justice sera la perdante de fait bah
écoutez là pour le moment ça me semble
très largement le cas la juridiction en
elle-même est minée elle-même par des
conflits
d'intérêts dont on vient de parler le
ministre lui-même considère sa position
comme une une position de combattant par
rapport à un corps judiciaire qui le
menace je rappelle quand même un que le
conflit d'intérêt c'est la loi et que
les juges appliquent la loi il
considèrent que le conflit d'intérêt est
ici prise égale d'intérêt ils ne font
qu'appliquer la loi le ministre de son
côté lui décide de son propre chef de sa
propre volonté de sa propre initiative
de les poursuivre par une enquête
prédisciplinaire d'un côté il y a
l'application de la loi de l'autre côté
il y a un choix individuel Paul Cassia
vous vous avez été donc témoin pour
anticorps mardi à ce procès à défaut de
pouvoir être parti civile si je
comprends bien comment ça se déroule
concrètement et qu'est-ce que vous avez
qu'est-ce que vous avez expliqué dans
cette dans cette cour qui est publique
hein les journalistes onts bien c'est
public comme dans tous les tribunaux
suivre les audien je voudrais rappeler
qu'anticore c'est une association qui a
été créée en 2002 pour favoriser
l'éthique publique et qu'anticore dans
cette affaire a est la première à avoir
déposé plainte avant les syndicats de
magistrats donc ce n'est pas une affaire
qui concerne uniquement les rapports
entre le garde des saau et les
magistrats nous avons déposé plainte le
6 octobre 2020 les magistrats ont déposé
plainte en décembre 2020
alors ensuite c'est vrai que la la
juridiction est tout à fait particulière
elle est particulière alors que pour
revenir sur ce qu'a dit monsieur le
député il y a un instant ce qui est en
cause c'est pas l'impeachment du
ministre c'est simplement le fait qu'il
a commis il peut avoir commis un délit
pénal de droit commun donc c'est ça le
paradoxe c'est qu'on est devant une
juridiction spécifique pour un délit
ordinaire et ben on y va tout de suite
on va regarder dans le détail comment
est composé cette juridiction pas comme
les autres le fonctionnement de la Cour
de Justice de la République c'est signé
Marco
Pomier comment est composée la CGR ils
sont 15 juges trois sont magistrats à la
Cour de cassation élu pour 3 ans par
leur père l'un d'eux préside la CJR
Dominique pote depuis 2019 les 12 autres
membres sont des juges parlementaires
six sénateurs six députés élu à chaque
renouvellement de l'Assemblée et du
Sénat quel est son rôle
sa fonction est de juger les membres du
gouvernement Premier ministre compris
pour des actes commis dans l'exercice de
leur fonction comment ça marche toute
personne française ou étrangère peut
saisir la CJR les plaintes individuelles
sont d'abord filtré par plusieurs
magistrats aucune constitution partie
civile n'est possible à la fin d'un
procès les 15 juges de l'instance vote à
bulletin secret et à la majorité absolue
sur la culpabilité du prévenu sur la
peine infligée aussi seul recours
possible pour un condamné le pourvoit en
cassation quelles affaires jugées par la
CGR
ministres et trois secrétaires d'État
ont déjà été jugés par l'institution
l'affaire la plus emblématique celle du
sang contaminé
1999 Laurent Fabius Premier ministre à
l'époque des fait est relaxé son
ex-secrétaire d'État lui est reconnu
coupable condamné mais dispensé de peine
tout comme chrtine
2016ot coupable de négligence pour sa
gestion de l'arbitrage entre Bernard
tapis et le Crédit Lyonnais la CJR
décrié pour la clémence de certains
verdict et la partialité des juges
symbole aussi pour certains d'une
justice d'exception à deux vitesses
François Hollande avait promis de la
supprimer Emmanuel Macron aussi mais
aucun n'a réussi à réviser la
Constitution Paul CIA je vous redonne la
parole donc 5 sur 12 députés membres de
cette parlementair membres de cette CJR
Cour de Justice de la République
appartiennent à la majorité est-ce que
pour vous ça crée
d'emblé un soupçon de partialité même
s'il prête serment il faut le rappeler
il prête serment ils ont il et ell ont
des habits de juges donc quand on les
voit on pense qu'on a affaire à des
vrais magistrats ou des vrais
magistrates mais ce qui pose problème
c'est pas tellement qu'il a cinq
parlementairire qui soit à priori
favorable au ministre ce qui pose
problème c'est qu'il y ait 12
parlementaires qui est qui ont une
opinion préconçue un préjugé sur le
ministre qu'il soit favorable ou
défavorable n'a pas d'importance ce qui
est gênant et ce qui est inadmissible
dans devant une juridiction ordinaire
c'est qu'il y a un préjugé politique
quel qu'il soit ça c'est tout à fait
inacceptable c'est inédit il n'y a pas
d'autre cours en France pas d'autre
juridiction où un tel préjugé est admis
il est inérant au fonctionnement de la
Cour et c'est inacceptable il faut la
supprimer pour vous c'est inacceptable
la remplacer il y a par construction un
vice dans la neutralité de cette
juridiction donc il faut absolument
réformer la cour ça vient d'être dit par
le reportage et cette réforme elle est
envisagée de manière assez consensuelle
depuis 2012 elle n'a jamais été mise en
œuvre pourquoi pourquoi chaque président
promet sa suppression sa réforme et
pourquoi systématiquement il ne le fait
pas Denis Salas parce que parce qu'il y
a dans notre culture politique euh c'est
très ancien une une image de la
souveraineté parlementaire qui a
beaucoup de mal à accepter un contrôle
sur elle-même la Haute Cour la Haute
Cour qui était la figure antérieure à la
cour de J de la République n'a jamais
fonctionné parce que le parlementaire ne
s'estimit souverain dans sa dans son
dans son comportement il il il réusait
tout toute forme de de contrôle et la
CGR retrouve en quelque sorte cette ce
sentiment de souveraineté sans sans
contrôle sans acceptation de contrôle et
qui se perpétue finalement à travers à
travers les â une question de culture
politique derrière cette cette cette
culture politique ou comment dire
concurrence de légitimité oui
souveraineté populaire contre
souveraineté judiciaire bah je pense que
c'est le séaration des pouir c'est le
cœur des problèmes d'un côté vous avez
ce que pent les magistrats une culture
du droit de l'application de la loi que
eux-mêmes mettent en œuvre dans cette
dans cette réforme dans cette dans cette
cours et de notre côté la culture
parlementaire la culture politique qui
ignore très souvent par par par par si
vousz par par par mes connaissances le
fonctionnement de la loi de de la de la
justice de son de son de son déroulement
son application Christopher feisberg
c'est la nature même de de cette cour he
et et de sa composition qui qui pose
problème qui qui qui jette le soupçon
est-ce qu'il faut la changer mais bon
évidemment on pourrait on pourrait
l'améliorer déjà ça demande une réforme
constitutionnel et évidemment par
principe une rformelle ça prend toujours
du temps
soustitutionnelle c'est un débat qui est
d'ailleurs actuel alors pourquoi pas
mais encore une fois il faut quand même
se rendre compte de la spécificité de
juger des des actes qui sont liés à
l'exercice du pouvoir à l'exercice de
l'État on a Édouard Philippe qui a été
premier ministre pendant le covid on a
Olivier verrand qui a été ministre de la
santé pendant le covid Agnès Buzin aussi
qui ont été aussi je veux dire on se
rend compte que dans un moment de crise
comme ce qu'on a vécu pendant le covid
avec des choses qui étaient totalement
exceptionnelles jamais vu c'est la
responsabilité pénale qui se substitue à
la responsabilité politique pour vous
c'est d'abord une responsabilité
politique je ne sais pas moi devant les
électeurs qui devrait être la première
légit c'est ça que vous dites je dis pas
forcément que ça je dis simplement que
quand on est dans l'exercice du pouvoir
on prend des décisions qui dépassent le
simple fonctionnement individuel de ce
que l'on fait et je veux dire qu'il faut
a il faut aussi protéger protéger la
décision politique le risque c'est que
si on met dans un une Cour de droit
commun n'importe quel fait le risque
c'est que plus personne ne prenne de
décision plus personne ne prenneent le
risque qui est vous a sign je je vous a
signalé évidemment la question du covid
éit particulière puisqu'elle était
totalement exceptionnelle et que
globalement personne n'a fait les choses
parfaitement partout dans le monde
chacun pourrait être repris et le risque
évidemment c'est que face à une
jurisdiction de droit commun tout le
monde soit au fond logé à la même
enseigne et qu'il n'y ait pas cette
exception qui est que on doit aussi
prendre en considération les risques
inhérant de la prise du pouvoir Eugénie
Bastier oui non juste de choses je moi
j'ai troué je trouvais que la politique
du covid mené par le gouvernement était
aberrante mais j'ai trouvé absolument
scandaleux que la CJR fasse faire une
perquisition des ministres c'est
absolument contraire à toute exercice de
politique et si on rentre là-dedans on
on en sort pas et ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on parle de l'irresponsabilité
des politiques mais précisément la
question que soulevit du P mariti c'est
celle de l'irresponsabilité des juges en
France parce que qui qui contrôle les
politiques beaucoup de gens contrôlent
les politiques mais personne ne contrôle
les juges et effectivement qui jugera
les juges c'est une vraie question et
aujourd'hui je trouve que le politique
en France ce n'est pas Goliat c'est
Guliver il est entravé en permanence par
les juges il est sans cesse remis en
question le nombre de démissions en cas
alors on va aller voir le magistrat
narrte juges Monsieur C est toujours
secrétaire général de l'Élysée
monsieurti
toujour
TR si les juges ent le pouvoir politique
ils sont pas très efficaces juste
justeotandême parlons même pas de de la
surinterprétation d'Ét de droit parce
moi je partage
l'idé je partage l'idée que il faut
évidemment des gardes fou conseilétat
avait d'ailleurs formulé une proposition
d'une juridiction spécialisée mais qu'on
peut pas continuer avec cette espèce
d'anachronisme qui est la Cour de
Justice de la République vous avez
rappelé les ce qu'est sa composition euh
c'est on a besoin aussi que nos
compatriotes soient rassurés dans
l'exercice des décisions de justice et
je suis évidemment pour qu'on met des
gardes de fous évidemment qu'il faut il
faut pas entraver la décision politique
mais on doit être capable dans une
démocratie adulte en fait il faut passer
à l'âge adulte maintenant de la
démocratie française et on doit être
capable de pas perpétuer des schémas qui
datent d'une époque où il y avait oui
une moindre exigence transpar démocrati
c'est bien plus
aujourd ça me fait sourire votre
affirmation madame parce que il y a un
corps d'inspection qui a mobilisé
monsieur Dupont Moretti il y a un
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature qui
assure si vous voulez le contrôle
disciplinaire des juges qui aa un
rapport annuel et même sur la
présomption d'innocence regardez un
magistrat qui est confronté à un délit
quel qu'il soit dans l'exer de ses
fonctions il est présumé innocent mais
il est immédiatement suspendu par le
Conseil pén donc il est pas du tout dans
une impunité il est suspendu et il y a
une procédure d'interdiction temporaire
ù pendant qu'il est mis en
examen au même moment où il est il est
effectivement en dehors de ses fonctions
donc le ministre lui a un privilège un
privilège extraordinaire par rapport à
ses magistrats lui il reste en fonction
alors que le magistrat lui il doit
quitter s fonction c'est un chantage on
l' trs bien expliqué je voudrais qu'on
précise aussi une chose qui rend encore
plus compliqué l'histoire où tout le
monde se tient un peu par la barbichette
c'est que s'il est condamné Éric dupô
mariti là quittera le le gouvernement et
ça il s'est engagé c'est ce qu'il a dit
et donc et donc ça rend encore plus
compliqué cette affaire puisque tout le
monde le sait dans cette dans cette s
c'est une donne qu'il faut voilà prendre
en compte oh ben on a déjà vu des
engagements qui n'ont pas été respectés
le monsieur Dupont Moretti s'était
engagé à devenir jamais ministre bon
mais ça peut influencer aussi cette
cours forcément c'est quand même juste
curieux qu'on soit passer du procès de
la CGR au procès des magistrats donc
c'est débat déb s'agissant de la CJR il
est évidemment très important de laisser
les ministres et les secrétaires d'État
exercer leurs fonction il n'est pas
question que tout un chacun puisse à
tout moment saisir le juge ordinaire
pour empêcher euh un gouvernement de
fonctionner c'est pourquoi les projets
de réforme qui avaient été présentés en
2012 et en 2017 prévoyit que les
ministres pouvaient être jugés par la
juridiction ordinaire mais avec un
préalable bien évidemment mais avec un
filtre préalable pour éviter que
n'importe qui puisse saisir à n'importe
quel moment un juge pour empêcher
l'action
ministèreou le filtre comme il en existe
aujourd'hui devant le CJR il y a
aujourd'hui au moins parce qu' déjà des
procédures judiciaires en amont de
l'arrivée devant cette Cour bien
évidemment et donc ces filtres là
doivent être transposés dev
le absolument ce même filtre un filt
comparable doit être transposé devant le
juge ordinaire ce qui est important
c'est qu'il n'y ait pas de jugement par
un entre soi c'est très c'est
inconfortable je le dis comme témoin de
rentrer dans une salle d'audience et de
voir effectivement un prévenu qui garde
des sauts avec son ancien subordonné
d'un côté et des hommes et des femmes
politiques de l'autre qu'il qu'il
connaît qu'il fréquente c'est tout à
fait anormal Benjamin Lucas est-ce que
une réforme de cette cour en ramenant on
va dire le ministre ou l'ex-ministre
pour des faits de durant son exercice
devant une cour classique de de
justiciable mais avec un filtre ça vous
conviendrait oui il faut en discuter
deux choses de choses choses on a'urait
pas la même problématique si Monsieur
Dupont morti vous dites il y a y a les
gens qui le jugent savent que ils ont
aussi entre leur mains son avenir
politique bah j'aurais aimé par par sa
démission par le fait que le Président
de la République prenne ses respons
abilité qu'il n'est que à juger éc
Dupont morétier et pas le ministre de la
Justice n moi je ne suis pas juriste il
y en a ici qui qui qui le sont par
contre je je suis un responsable
politique et je regarde aussi ce qui se
raconte politiquement et je suis très
inquiet pour notre démocratie je vous le
dis parce que quand on reprend des
argumentaires qu'on entend chez Monsieur
Trump chez Monsieur bolsonaro chez
Monsieur Orban pour dénoncer le
gouvernement des juges ou jadis chez
Monsieur Berlusconi ou chez Monsieur
Sarkozi de la part de ceux qui se sont
érigés comme le temple du progressisme
le camp de la raison et cetera tout ça
m'inquiète parce qu'on est dans une
espèce de de de dérive aussi qui est
dans qui prépare quoi qui prépare le
fait que demain une extrême droite au
pouvoir pourra très bien s'en prendre à
la justice qui est un fondement de notre
démocratie notre État de droit Donal
Trump Donald Trump les grandes différen
c'est qu'il il remet en question la
décision de la justice c'est pas ce
queti dit que s'il est condamné il
quittera ses fonctions là vous allez par
Trump arrive qu'il se passe quoi qu'il
se passe vraiment je vois une différence
il y a un procès et procès considérons
qu'il est équitable parce que les partis
ne sont des parties prenantes avec des
visions impartiales pour terminer ce
débat Deiss cette question quand même
est-ce que le problème ne vient tout
simplement pas d'Emmanuel Macron qui a
choisi Éric Dupont mariti qui est en
guerre faut le dire c'est vrai avec les
magistrats depuis toujours et encore
plus depuis qu'il est gardé sa et
choisit en plus de le maintenir au
gouvernement est-ce que au fond c'est
pas ça le péché originel ça a mis au
premier plan la passion politique du
coup du coup effectivement le ce que
vous appelez le F moi j'appelle ça les
institutions ont été en quelque sorte
étranglé parasité par cette ces passions
d'un côté la passion du ministre qui est
effectivement en vœux au magistrat de
l'autre côté aussi les magistrats qui
aussi leurs syndicats qui sont qui ont
déclaré qui ont dit c'est une
déclaration de guerre et je trouve il
est très important pour la démocratie
comme vous l'avez dit de de mettre pour
faire pour faire l'économie de ces
passions pour les atténuer pour les
modérer de d'introduire aussi du droit
de de faire jouer les institutions qui
vont filtrer les passions politiques et
qui vont permettre effectivement peu à
peu d'acheminer effectivement ce que
nous attendons la vérité dans le conflit
d'intérêt c'est la commission des
requêtes la commission d'instruction et
le jugement final avec ses réquisitions
et sa motivation et ben voilà on
dépassionne on fait tomber un peu le le
niveau de tension ramène la raison
peut-être que voilà on trouve le début
d'un d'un changement d'une d'une réforme
possible même si ça prendra du temps si
Monsieur Lucas vous êtes on relance pas
le débat mais c'est pas un débat mais je
dis simplement par rapport à cette
accusation qu' naurait pas fallu choisir
dès le début monsieur Lucas il est très
virulent contre la
et c'est votre droit c'est
votre syndicats de police aujourd'hui si
vous arrivez au responsabilité vous
disqualifiez de devenir
ministreintérieur ça poserait aussi un
problème politique vous avez le droit
d'avoir des positions qui sont
critiquesite Contin vous voulez dans
LESISS arrêter là parce que on a envie
de parler aussi du livre de J Basier
merci messieurs C passionnant merci
beaucoup et c'était important d'avoir
ici même sur la Chaîne Parlementaire un
tel débat vous restez avec moi Eugénie
Bastier dans une dizaine de minutes les
partis prix de nos affranchis ce soir y
ELG sinterroge le président doit-il
marcher ce dimanche contre
l'antisémitisme le RN qui sera dans le
cortège est-il encore un parti d'extrême
droite c'est la question de pierrehenri
tavoyot ce soir et puis vous Elsa et
moningava de quoi nous parlez-vous ce
soir de la loi immigration va essayer de
décrypter la version du Sénat et se
projeter sur les débats à l'Assemblée à
tout à l'heure les amis mais d'abord
comme promis on se plonge dans votre
livre jénie basstiier la dictature des
ressentis chez plomb ça n'est pas une
menace nous dites-vous elle est déjà là
dis-moi ce que tu ressens de quoi tu
souffres je te dirai qui tu es alors
comment peut-on encore s'opposer sans
s'offenser regardez c'est dans
l'invitation de Marco Pomier on en parle
toutes les deux juste
après si on vous invite Eugénie Bastier
c'est parce que vous lancez un SOS il
faut sauver la liberté de penser à
l'heure de la dictature des ressentis
dites-vous dans ce monde où tout
reposerait sur l'émotion l'image la
vitesse et la culture du mois jeu chacun
se repli sur soi sur son vécu résultat
selon vous c'est la porte ouverte au
sectarisme à vous entendre on ne peut
plus débattre avec n'importe qui
discuter avoir une conversation débattre
c'est accepter l'idée de être dérangé
dans ses convictions jeune pousse de la
droite conservatrice pour certains RAC
et fille spirituelle d'Éric Zemour pour
d'autres je l'assume totalement je suis
conservatrice quoi qu'il en soit votre
parcours a été fulgurant Eugénie Bastier
à seulement 24 ans vous entrez au Figaro
éditorialiste essayiste dans vos livres
comme dans vos chroniques des opinions
tranchées souvent clivantes mais assumé
antilibéral contre l'avortement et le
mariage gay jugé antiféministe aussi
pour vos prises de position polémique
sur le mouvement mitthou je je m'éiche
contre la la victimisation excessive en
disant la la main au fesse n'a jamais
tué personne c'est vrai la main au f n'a
jamais tué personne c'est vrai ou pas
bref vous n'avez pas la langue dans
votre poche votre dernier ouvrage en
témoigne de années de pensée
intellectuelle compilé et des coups de
gueule pour alerter sur le grand
renoncement face à l'immigration pour
s'offusquer de la mcdonalisation de
l'éducation nationale qui place
l'identité des élèves sur un piédestal
pour fustiger aussi le dairw une hérésie
de la religion du progrès d'après vous
alors pour déconstruire les
déconstructeurs vous invoquez des
contemporains à contrecourant Alain
fininkelcroot Michel Welbeck ubert
Vedrine sans oublier les écrivains
d'hier Montaigne Camu Bernanos alors
Eugénie Bastier si l'idéologie W est
avant tout anglo-saxonne ne
surestimez-vous pas son ampleur en
France
[Musique]
réponse
eu je pense effectivement qu'il y a une
différence entre la France et les
États-Unis sur ce planl parce que
justement je parle de la dictature des
ressentis de ce culte de l'émotion de
l'idée que les opinions deviennent des
blessures et je pense qu'en France on a
un certain nombre d'antidotes à ça parce
qu'on est le pays on a on est pays de la
raison c'est on adore les débats alors
ça c'est sûr on aime beaucoup s'écharper
pour des mots et cetera mais on arrive
peut-être plus à mettre à distance
l'émotion euh le la le témoignage on est
plus on est un pays de l'abstraction
aussi on aime beaucoup les grands mots
liberté égalité laïcité mais vous dites
quand même qu'il ne se passe plus un
jour sans que le militantisme W ne fasse
l'actualité on en est là oui c'est vrai
on le voit encore ces jours-ci je trouve
sur la guerre le conflit
israëlo-palestiniens il y a des échos
wok qu'on voit tous les jours c'està-d
la manière don d'ailleurs c'est récupéré
par le par le wisme sur les campus
justement puisque vous en parlez je je
voulais vous en parler un peu plus tard
mais puisque vous en parlez euh c'est
c'est un un impressionnant même Harvard
seul le régime d'apartè d'Israël est en
faute dans les massacres du 7 octobre
Colombia la résistance à l'occupation
des terres justifie tout même les
massacres et l'Université de Virginie
mais j'en ai pris quelques une seulement
le 7 octobre une étape vers la
libération de la Palestine est-ce que
c'est une forme de lecture W de ce qui
se passe entre Israël et le ramas
aujourd'hui qui qui est à l'œuvre dans
les grandes universités d'élitees ou
bien sûr vous avez deux phénomènes on
voit dans ces manifestations des
manifestations d'islamisme à travers les
slogans Allah la Akbar des des drapeaux
de daesh en Allemagne on voit des
manifestations de ce qu'on peut appeler
le wisme qui récupère cette cause et qui
le fait parce que au nom de quoi et je
crois que c'est un grand lien avec la
dictature des ressentis parce que le
wquisme c'est l'idée que quand on
appartient à une communauté on est par
essence coupable ou victime et donc les
si on apparti dominant ou dominer et
dans l'imaginaire W les Israéliens les
Juifs appartiennent au camp des
dominants d'ailleurs ils sont moins
considérés comme juifs mais comme comme
blancs blanc et parce que il serait
voilà on réduit Israël à un État
colonial et donc comme le colonialisme
est le pire des crimes dans la pensée W
tout est permis en réalité contre Israël
y compris le terrorisme et c'est ça le
la clé lecture qu'applique effectivement
c'est campus ces étudiants W au conflit
israëlo-palestiniens et c'est
effectivement assez effrayant jus par la
jeunesse vous dites la dictature des
ressentis et pourquoi pas la dictature
des ressentiments pour l'instant c'est
un débat intellectuel c'est un débat
culturel il a des effets évidemment tous
les jours mais il est comment dire dans
dans les discussions dans la manière de
voir le monde il ne se traduit pas par
de la
violence trouvez qu'on est là quand on
voit certaines manifestations aux
États-Unis que ce soit à l'occasion de
la mort de George Floyd ou aujourd'hui
du conflit israël-palestinien on a des
manifestations de violence for quand on
voit qu'il y a certain débat bas qui
sont annulés ou qui sont ou des
professeurs qui sont virés d'université
aux États-Unis on est quand même déjà
dans le domaine de de de conséquences
concrètes effectivement qui sont qui
sont là déjà là et et vous parlez de
ressentiment le mot est intéressant
parce que je pense qu'effectivement ce
ce culte des ressentis cette idée que je
suis blessé par une opinion qui me
dérange et que finalement l'expression
même d'opinion est en soi une agression
elle conduit à une forme de
d'enfermement de ce ressenti se mie en
ressentim et vous avez aujourd'hui une
grande détresse même de cette jeunesse
je pense W qui a été d'ailleurs c'est un
c'est un comment dire c'est un pour moi
le le wokisme est une une forme de
croyance de luxe c'est-à-dire c'est ça
touche une jeunesse en réalité
extrêmement privilégiée qui qui peut se
payer le luxe de trouver finalement des
des des des dominations là il y en a pas
des des des inégalités là il y en a
presque plus par voà c'est tout à fait
petit bourgeois et c'est tout à fait
même d'ailleurs vous êtes allé à siencep
vous racontez ça aujourd'hui vos anciens
camarades ne vous reconnaissent plus ou
n'arrivent pas à comprendre vos parties
prix c'est ouii j'ai j'ai j'ai subi une
forme de sectarisme qui m'a touché
personnellement parce que c'est avec des
gens de qui j'étais vraiment proche et
qui moi ça ne me vrait pas l'idée de de
les exclure de ma vie pour leurs
opinions ou même de leur de mettre une
distance il se trouve que moi il voilà
ils m'ont ils ont jugé que ce n pas
possible il vous ont
gostéiné et je je trouve ça terrible
parce qu'il y a alors le sectarisme
toujours été présent à gauche
intellectuel le Sartre qui dit tout
anticommuniste est un chien qui se
brouille avec Camu qui se brouille avec
Aaron ça toujours existé mais
aujourd'hui ce ce sectarisme est encore
pire parce qu'il repose sur le Patos sur
le sentiment c'est-à-dire c'est l'idée
que non non seulement tu je ne suis pas
d'accord avec toi et tu n'es pas
d'accord avec moi mais tu m'as blessé tu
me fais du mal tu me fais souffrir et je
trouve que c'est extrêmement difficile
de répondre à quelqu'un qui fait des
opinions en soi une forme de blessure et
c'est contre ça que j'essaie de de
lutter dans ce Liv alors justement on va
venir à la lutte c'est intéressant il y
a plein d'exemples très concrets vous
parlez de l'emmoji encein celui-là vous
l'aimez pas du tout là on est dans la
dictature des ressentis parce que voilà
vous dites vous dites que c'est
l'alliance du W et de la silicone zé non
mais dire de dire qu' de dire qu'on il
suffit de se sentir homme ou femme pour
être un homme et ou une femme on est
typiquement pour moi dans la dictature
du ressenti c'est-à-dire l'idée que
finalement il y a une sorte de de de de
de d'individualisme et de subjectivisme
absolu qui fait que les faits n'existent
plus il suffit juste de proclamer que
Onon est quelque chose pour l'être et et
si les autres ne sont pas d'accord avec
vous ce sont des des des nazis c'est
c'est vraiment pour moi typiquement un
exemple de la dictature des ressentis
bon après vous vous êtes aussi très
radical dans la manière dont vous les
dénoncez ils sont pas forcément dans
dans une espèce de fermeture absolue à
tout échange non vous voyez des nuances
dans ce courant de pensée ou pas oui
sans doute après je pense quand même
qu'il y a une il y a un phénomène
idéologique très puissant qui comme il a
été d'ailleurs une forme de marxisme
autre fois qui prend le relais
d'ailleurs de ces grandes idéologies et
qui et qui pour le coup je pense que la
radicalité est plutôt de ce côté-là moi
je ne je ne demand je d'ailleurs je je
ne demande l'exclusion de personne du
débat public je pense que c'estes
doivent avoir le droit d'avoir la parole
je ne suis pas du tout pour qu'on le on
leur coupe le micro contrairement à eux
qui eux qui d'ailleurs vous aorez les
observer pour mieux les déconstruire
c'est c'est un peu votre votre passion
au quotidien Mme d' passion il reste des
des raisons d'espérer car des
contemporains à contre courants sont
quand même très présents dans le dans
l'espace médiatique vous les citez
Michel welbec Gaspar prou Jérôme
Fourquet Alain finelcot mais ce qui m'a
intéressé c'est c'est vraiment les
écrivains les intellectuels il y a plein
plein d'intellectuels que vous citez on
a choisi Pierre Nora nous pourquoi
pourquoi Pierre Noa il faudrait
l'écouter et le lire aujourd'hui déjà
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a une une
immense expérience et un regard sur la
société française intellectuelle qui
date enfin de presque un domicile siècle
d'édition il a édité les premiers enfin
tous les grands penseurs dans les années
70 70 jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc il a
vraiment une amplitude et un regard qui
est qui est extrêmement long et c'est et
c'est ça qui est passionnant quand on
discute avec lui c'est qu'il a cette
profondeur de chant et en même temps je
trouve de la lucidité sur certains
sujets c'est quelqu'un qui vient de la
gauche mais qui n'est pas aveugle pour
autant à certains débats qui qui qui
voilà qui qui qui qui voit ce qu'il doit
voir et donc voilà je trouve que c'est
un personnage de notre vie publique euh
intéressant qui qui a qui a un parcours
voilà c'était intéressant aussi de de
voir que vous pouvevez aussi une
référence de de gauche le remède pour
vous c'est la littérature alors il y a
Peggy l'antiboomer il y a Camu il y a
solgenitcine on en a choisi un euh parce
que vous défendez aussi euh la la
dimension comment dire catholique de la
société française en tout cas s racine
ses valeurs c'est Bernanos écrivain
chrétien homme d'hier et d'après-demain
écrivez-vous vous pourquoi parce que
l'homme d'hier parce que il est c'est un
homme qui a vécu essentiellement au 20e
siècle et qui était dans ces débats là
et qui qui était profondément enraciné
dans une tradition tradition politique
tradition intellectuelle tradition
religieuse qui était profondément
attaché à la France patriote qui venait
de l'Action française enfin de du
moracisme qui son progressivement
détaché et en même temps qui a su voir
les enjeux très nouveaux de son temps la
technique par exemple il a des il a des
des phrases prophétiques sur la la
robotisation du monde la place que va
prendre la technique dans le monde de
demain et et donc voilà c'est ça que
j'aime en fait chez Bernanos chez pegy
chez Camu chez on pourrait citer aussi
orw qui pas dans dans ce livre mais ce
sont des gens qui appartenaient à un
camp mais qui ont su regarder penser
contre même penser contre leur camp voir
ce qu' comme le dit pegy il faut voir ce
que il faut dire ce que l'on voit mais
ce qu' est encore plus difficile c'est
de voir ce que l'on voit et je trouve
que c'est extrêmement pertinent dans le
monde dans lequel on vit o beaucoup
parfois on a des illèes idéologiques il
faut toujours questionner ces illères là
parce que et moi je j'essaie de le faire
aussi pour voir pour voir vraiment voilà
le d'ailleurs le choix le choix de ces
grands écrivains en témoigne à à la fin
du livre merci beaucoup Eugénie Bastier
la dictature des ressentis sauver la
liberté de penser hein on en est là quel
défi c'est à lire aux éditions plomb et
c'est voilà vous revisitez les les
différents articles du du Figaro de de
ces dernières années vous restez avec
moi c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur part prix ils vont
vous faire réagir on les accueille tout
de suite et il a ELG de France interne
nous rejoint comme chaque jeudi soir en
compagnie de Pierre-Henri tavoyot du
collège de philosophie installez-vous
bonsoir à vous deux ravi de vous
retrouver on va commencer par Bourbon
Express bien sûr comme chaque soir
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée vous
nous la racontez ce soir Elsa moudingava
bonsoir à vous bonsoir je vais vous
parler d'un article c'est l'article qui
rend fou du projet de loi immigration
l'article 3 celui sur la régularisation
des sans papiers dans les métiers en
tenstion les sénateurs on le rappelle le
Sénat est à majorité à droite et bien
ils l'ont supprimé hier soir c'est une
victoire pour le président du groupe LR
au Sénat Bruno rotaillot c'est une
victoire politique on l'a bien vu
d'ailleurs hier puisque le ministre a
donné un avis très défavorable à notre
amendement qui supprimait l'article 3
l'article 3 c'était une machine non
seulement à régulariser mais c'est une
machine à frauder c'est une belle
victoire très franchement très
franchement il y a 48 heures vous
m'auriez dit que ça se serait terminé
comme ça je vous aurais pas cru alors
victoire cri la droite sénatoriale sauf
que et bien quand on interroge la
majorité ici à l'Assemblée ils ne sont
pas du tout du tout d'accord pourquoi et
bien parce que l'article 3 est supprimé
mais il y a un article 4 bis qui est
certes un peu plus dur mais quel mérite
d'exister pour Florent bouer c'est le
rapporteur général du texte ici à
l'Assemblée les sénateurs LR font un pas
et plus qu'un pas vers la politique
ciblée de régularisation les sénateurs
etir il y a encore quelques jours indiqu
pas de politique de
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier en France là nous allons vers une
politique de régularisation ciblé
accepté par les sénateurs LR ça c'est le
fait politique majeur pour des
responsables de la majorité Bruno
rotaillo en acceptant un compromis sur
les régularisations il a mangé son
chapeau il a surtout embarrassé les
députés LR ici à l'Assemblée pourquoi
parce qu'Olivier marlex le président du
groupe et éctil président du parti eux
ils sont sur une ligne ils ne veulent
pas voter ce texte mais on le sait les
62 députés du groupe sont tous sur des
lignes très différentes l'intérêt
tactique de la majorité c'est de diviser
les républicains donc division à droite
on a compris mais division également
attention au sein même de la majorité
oui ça peut tanguer ce matin dans Le
Figaro coup de pression de Sacha aier je
dirais même coup de pression mensuel du
président de la commission des lois
représentant de l'ail gauche de la
macronie à l'Assemblée nous rétablirons
le texte ambitieux de l'exécutif sur
l'immigration le gouvernement est
prévenu alors le débat sur l'immigration
à l'Assemblée va commencer le 27
novembre si je dis pas de bêtises c'est
ça et le 11 décembre dans l'hémicycle et
on commence déjà en coulisse à compter
les voix ouais on a ressorti les
calculettes cell qu'on bien chauffé
pendant la réforme des retraites on le
rappelle 289 voix c'est la majorité
absolue la majorité en dispose de 251 il
en manque donc 38 on essaie d'avoir
celle du groupe Lyot le groupe petit
mais costaud à l'assemblée qui est très
bien traité en ce moment et puis on
cherche bah un vote parci une abstention
par là sinon s'il en manque à la fin on
sait comment ça finira en 493 bon verra
on verra merci s RIM c'était très clair
et passionnant comme chaque soir Elsa on
enchaîne avec vous yel ira ira pas c'est
la grande question le président de la
République n'a toujours pas dit ses
intentions concernant la grande marche
pour la République et contre
l'antisémitisme quen pensez-vous est-ce
qu'il doit marcher lui aussi vous me
direz que c'est peut-être un peu
réducteur de focaliser sur une seule
personne par parce que l'enjeu dimanche
c'est d'abord de se compter de savoir
combien de Français s'ils seront
nombreux à faire bloc à dire stop à la
haine le carré de tête on le sait sera
symbolique les ex-présidents François
Hollande Nicolas Sarkozy ensuite les
ex-premier ministres et puis pour le
gouvernement actuel Élisabeth borne ça
c'est confirmer faut-il en plus que le
chef de l'État mène ce cortège c'était
le cas en mê
1990 après la profanation du cimetière
de Carpentra François mitteran devant
200000 personnes à Paris c'était aussi
l'image de François and rappelez-vous
Brats bratsous avec 40 chefs d'État et
de gouvernement en janvier 2015 après
les attentats de de Charlie et de l'hyer
cacher pour l'instant je vais être frond
avec vous on a aucune confirmation de
l'Élysée sur sa présence ou non dimanche
la seule chose qu'on sait c'est qu'il y
aurait une grande expression importante
forte en presse écrite avant la marche
et pour vous ça ne suffit pas non le
Président il incarne la République il il
est le garant de ses valeurs bien sûr
que la marche aura une autre dimension
un autre poids s'il est là sa présente
limiterait les parasitages ce serait
l'assurance que la marche n'est pas
dévoyée par des politiques qui ont
d'autres arrière-pensées dont l'histoire
ne les autorise pas à venir comme si de
rien n'était comme si on pouvait
impunément être l'héritier de Jean-Marie
Le Pen ou tenir des propos
révisionnistes comme Éric Zemour il ne
faut pas tout inverser c'est à l'extrême
droite de se regarder dans la glace et
de dire si elle y a sa place dans la
marche pas aux autres et s'il ne vient
pas le président de la République est-ce
que ça pourrait être mal interprété
alors si c'est par crainte que que son
message que le message que ça envoie
brouille sa politique étrangère au
moment où il cherche à obtenir un cesser
le feu et donc à se mettre à cui
distance des deux parties ça ça serait
une erreur n'ajoutons pas des fractures
nationales au fractures internationales
vous vous souvenez ces propos à
loocution du 12 octobre et bien
justement cette marche là elle consiste
à dire STOP à l'importation en France
des tensions venu du Proche Orient en un
mois il y a eu trois fois plus d'actes
antisémite que sur toute l'année 2022 or
les Juifs de France ne sont pas
responsables des bombardements sur Gaza
pas plus que les musulmans de France ne
sont comptables des pogromes du Hamas
dire non à l'antisémitisme ici en France
c'est pas dire oui à netanahou le député
insoumis David guireot vous l'avez
entendu sûrement il se fourvoie
complètement quand il dit que marcher
dimanche c'est soutenir de manière
inconditionnelle le nettoyage ethnique
je le cite de Gaza tout comme Maurice
léville patron de publicist lui aussi
vous avez peut-être entendu est excessif
quand il prétend que si on reste chez
soi dimanche c'est qu' tionne le Hamas
voilà dans ces temps troublés dans ces
temps éruptifs il y a il y a un besoin
de parole d'autorité savoir où on va
pourquoi on marche c'est donc aussi ça
le rôle et la fonction d'un président
donc d'être là dimanche dans la marche
merci beaucoup y Go allez réaction
eugbasti il doit y aller ça un peu de
hauteur dans ce qui est en train de
devenir un carnaval absolument
ahurissant où un tel demande à être à
3,50 de Marie Le Pen ou à 150 m il faut
un gros un petit cordon sanitaire en en
en béton armé ou je moi je trouve que ça
devient ridicule et je trouve d'ailleurs
que cette polémique sur le rassembl
national qui doit y aller ou pas est
ridicule parimais bien vous entendre sur
sur le président de la République 200000
personnes c'était Carpentra les années
90 très différent contexte extrêmement
différent il pouvit pas y avoir le Front
national de l'époque dans ce cortège
c'était des des des tombes profanées
aujourd'hui avec ce conflit avec ce qui
se passe dans le pays l'antisémitisme
explose les Juifs ont peur ils le disent
est-ce que le président absolument doit
marcher avec les français pour la
République qu'il doit défendre moi je
pense que oui il peut y aller il do il
doit peut-être oui il doit y aller parce
que effectivement le le le là il il y a
un phénomène un moment antisémite que
nous vivons en France qui est un moment
inédit et qui est un moment d'une rare
violence après si c'est y aller pour y
aller sans mettre les mots sur cet
antisémitisme d'où il vient est-ce qu'il
est-ce qu'il vient toujours de l'extrême
droite ou est-ce qu'il vient peut-être
de d'une autre partie de la population
notamment l'antisémitisme arabo
musulmanans qu'on a longtemps nié si
c'est pour juste se mon moner sans en
tirer les conséquences sur ce qu'on doit
faire dans le pays pour y remédier ça ne
servira à rien donc moi je veux bien je
voudrais qu'il y aille et qu'il en tire
les conséquence vous irez vous
d'ailleurs je suis malheureusement pas à
Paris ce weekend mais sinon j' serai
allé Go vous vous êtes d'accord il faut
qu'il parti parce qu'il faut qu'il parle
je pense qu'il faut qu'il est deux il y
aura l'expression la grande expression
présidentielle presseécrite ou télé mais
en tout cas il y aura il y aura quelque
chose mais là il s'agit de d'être
cohérent avec la marche h voilà on verra
aussi l'ampleur de cette manifestation
qui sera qui sera évidemment scrutée de
près Pierre Henri vous vouliez c'est la
continuité exactement de la de la
chronique de yel revenir sur cette
marche on a vu les l'embarras la gêne
notamment avec la présence de Marine Le
Pen et du rassemblement nationale et
vous vous posez cette question ce soir
ce parti est-il encore d'extrême droite
oui c'est la question qui fâche mais je
crois qu'on peut l'aborder de manière un
peu dépassionné euh d'abord en
distinguant il y a trois sens possibles
d'extrême droite il y a il y a un
premier sens qui est purement
géographique ou topographique c'est ceux
qui se situent à l'extrême droite à
l'Assemblée voilà à l'hémicycle ça ça
date de août 1789 le vote sur le vetau
Royal donc de ce point de vuel oui le
parti de Ren est d'extrême droite après
il y a deux autres sens qu'il faut
ajouter plus idéologique le second sens
c'est un sens historique au fond c'est
un courant de la droite française qui a
été contre révolutionnaire qui s'est
prolongé dans les ligues fascistes qui a
atteint son apothéose peut-être sous le
régime de de Vichy qui a on dit dans le
le cadre de l'OAS il y a trois
caractéristiques je crois de ce de ce
mouvement politique c'est d'abord l'anti
parlementarisme deuxièmement cette
extrême droite c'est aussi ce qu'on peut
appeler la la révolution conservatrice
c'est pas simplement une position
réactionnaire c'est la phrase de de du
guépard de Visconti vous souvenez il
faut que rien tout change pour que rien
ne change c'est ça l'idéologie
révolutionnaire qu'and ça partir ça peut
être violent il faut tout changer mais
en même temps pe on revient au départ
puis troisème idée de cette de cette
c'est l'idée d'une pureté nationale
qu'il faut défendre c'est l'idée que la
nation c'est pas un plébiscite de tous
les jours comme disait Renand mais c'est
une substance mystique qui transcende
tous ses membres alors de ce point de
vue-là voilà on on a une première bonne
définition de l'extrême droite puis un
troisième sens qui est très important et
là on insiste sur le terme extrême
c'est-à-dire extrême extrémisme je
reprends à Pierre-André tagev cette idée
c'est que l'extrémisme c'est d'abord la
légitimation de la violence c'est
d'abord c'est ensuite une forme
d'intolérance à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur on discute pas et
troisièmement c'est une ce qu'on peut
appeler une forme de de de de de
fanatisme il y a une cause sacrée qu'il
faut absolument défendre et toutes les
fins justifie enfin cette fin justifie
tous les moyens alors on regarde tous
ces critères est-ce que ce parti le RN
d'aujourd'hui est d'extrême droite ou
pas alors si on est d'accord avec ces
critères on peut les discuter il me
semble que non le rassemblement national
ne coche plus les critères idéologiques
sur le plan idéologique les deux
changements spectaculaires entre
Jean-Marie Le Pen et Marine Le Pen c'est
sur la question en effet l'ané sémitisme
parce que je rappelle que Jean-Marie Le
Pen c'est l'homme du point de détail et
deuxièmement sur la question du la
laïcité aussi si je pu dire Marine Le
Pen s'est converti à la laïcité alors
que son père était dans un contexte de
catholicisme traditionnaliste même si
c'est une laïcité plus identitaire que
républicaine si on regarde l'autre
définition l'extrémisme alors de ce
point de vue-là bah c'est plutôt la
France insoumise qui l'incarne la
légitimation de la violence c'est la
France insoumise l'intolérance c'est la
France insoumise avec cette logique de
purge qui se développe et se déploie pas
le fanatisme il faut être honnête le
fanatisme c'est la grande cause à
laquelle on sacrifie tout bon la seule
cause du de LF c'est la conquête du
pouvoir donc bon c'est pas une grande
cause non plus alors s'il n'est plus
d'extrême droite à vous suivre qu'est-il
le RN aujourd'hui comment vous le situz
P on pe justement c'est un objet nouveau
qu'il faut arriver à définir de manière
un peu rigoureuse pour moi c'est un
parti de droite radical populiste et
illibérale au fond ce qui le caractérise
c'est pas non du tout comme le fascisme
une antidémocratie c'est une
hyperdémocratie et on veut d'une
certaine façon façon toujours plus de
peuple et toujours plus de pouvoir
toujours plus de peuple contre
l'oligarchie qui monopolie c'est ça le
populisme et toujours plus de pouvoir
c'est ça l'illibéralisme contre l'État
profond qui produit de l'impuissance
publique et donc ces deux dimensions
populiste et ilbéral me paraissent
vraiment définir aujourd'hui ce qu'est
le rassemblement national à mon sens
l'excommunication le procès en
excommunication morale à l'égard de
rassemblement nation est totalement
inefficace ça veut dire quand même ça ça
veut dire que au fond les 13 millions
d'électeurs qui ont voté pour Marine Le
Pen sont soit des salots soit des idiots
soit des idiots parce qu'ils ont voté
pour un parti dont ils n'ont pas vu
qu'il était raciste et fasciste soit des
salots parce qu'ils sont réellement
racistes et fascistes et je crois que si
on veut récupérer ces électeurs c'est
pas le bon message à faire passer h vous
êtes d'accord bah oui j'ai bien réaction
g je suis ass je suis assez d'accord
mais je crois pas seulement c'est aussi
injuste parce que je pense effectivement
le interational c'est comme vous savez
le le bateau de tzé c'est un bateau dont
le bateau dont avait changé toutes les
pièces en bois et à la fin on on disait
est-ce que c'est le même bateau bah
effectivement on a changé le nom on ils
les ont rompu avec le le le leur
fondateurs ils ont changé de doctrine y
a quelques ils ont rompu avec leur
fondateur vousouve il était exclu je éta
exclu du attendez j'ai pas terminé et
j'ai pas terminé et et je pense que
c'est c'est c'est injuste parce que
précisément la lutte contre le racisme
et l'antisémitisme repose sur quoi sur
le fait de ne pas assigner quelqu'un à
ses origines c'est précisément ce qu'on
fait avec Marine Le Pen c'est qu'on
laine en permanence à son père sa
généalogie assez injuste après je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est un parti
populiste et libéral et on peut le
qualifier autrement si l'extrême droite
c'est l'antisémitisme dans vos critères
il y en a il y en a un si les députés
actuels ou le patron actuel Jordan
Bardella du parti n'est pas capable de
dire que le patriarche Le Pen a eu des
propos antisémites a été condamné pour
ça alors il y a une filiation et donc
c'est l'extrême droite il y a une
reconnaissance ça je pense que c
dimension de rapport avec une histoire
qui ne veut pas passer oui ça je pense
qu'il y a il y a des vieux démons dans
le rassemblement national et de ce point
de vue-là on peut aussi lui objecter à
ce rassemblement national que ces vieux
démons probablement pourront être un
obstacle à sa prise de pouvoir et son
exercice du pouvoir mais c'est un procès
d'intention on s'arrête là en tout cas
c'est passionnant de vous écouter merci
à vous les affranchis merci Elsa à très
vite et merci Eugénie Bastier la
dictature des ressentis c'est-à-dire
chez plomb les antiw onont se jeter sur
cet ouvrage c'est une évidence allez on
s'arrête là c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi tout de
suite votre soirée documentaire
Jean-Pierre Gratien à
[Musique]
demain